I have a few questions uh because I know
you can't say too much uh I know that
the for the season is eight to ten
episodes whatever of those eight to ten
whatever the number finally is which one
are you most looking forward to fans
getting a look at
um what do you think I like learning
about the behind the scenes of making
movies TV shows what would surprise
people to learn about the making of this
show that they wouldn't expect
I think just how intense it is
um we just we dive really deep on the
struggles that each character goes
through and we don't hold back on that
at all so yeah I think that for sure uh
um so Dave said that he wrote all the
episodes and I'm curious what surprised
you about the writing in terms of uh his
writing on the show and what he was you
know building towards with the finale
well there's just so much history with
these characters so there's just so much
subtext which is very unique to this
show because there is an existing fan
base that know a lot and then there's
also
a whole bunch of fans that are
completely clueless right now that will
become fans so we had to cater to both
so the writing was very specific in
doing so in giving away enough that it's
an homage to what the fans already know
but not being so cryptic that new fans
can't understand it so it was it was a
very interesting balance to strike my
last thing for you uh which of your
friends and family are the most excited
that you're part of Star Wars oh my god
well my dad's really excited because
he's a big Star Wars fan but I have to
say a lot of my friends have popped out
of the woodwork as huge Star Wars fans
that I had no idea so that's been really
fun I just it's they they're everywhere
so quite a few people yeah quite a few
friends on that note I really can't wait
to see the series thank you for your
time thank you